creo que la convención republicana pues
hay que resaltar lo peligroso que ha
sido lo peligroso que ha sido el
socialismo por ejemplo latinoamérica lo
peligroso que sería para eeuu llegar a
tener este esto implantado en su país es
hablaron de lo grave por ejemplo que
sería para ellos tener un presidente
como bailén que
está apoyado por personas como la humana
como bernie sanders como alessandro
cosas o cortes por ejemplo quienes
siguen insistiendo en no juzgar y en ver
con buena cara el socialismo por ejemplo
en venezuela y que no tildan a nicolás
maduro como un dictador que es realmente
lo que es
resulta llamativo el desenlace que ha
tenido esta convención republicana que
concluyó en la noche con el discurso del
presidente de trump y quien hizo un
repaso de los logros de su
administración el manejo habló del
manejo de la crisis del cobat y de los
peligros ante la posibilidad pues de que
yo guayo bailén tome esta presidencia y
habló también de de poder traerlas a las
tropas a casa de mejorar el sistema
educativo de reforzar las leyes
migratorias de evitar a toda costa la
entrada de inmigrantes ilegales creo que
lo importante sería que los estados
unidos realmente retomé el sendero de la
libertad que han marcado a los padres
fundadores de este país
es un camino de libertades económicas el
libre mercado de libertades individuales
y empezar a reducir el tamaño del estado
cosa que no ha pasado durante esta
administración que más bien ha aumentado
en gasto público en déficit y en deuda
señora porras que podemos ver de ahora
en adelante en las campañas políticas de
cara a estas elecciones de noviembre
pues vamos a ver una pelea bastante
reñida vemos por ejemplo como en estados
como el estado de florida en donde
generalmente trump siempre lleva la
delantera pues tenemos que estar
encabezando las encuestas bailén pero
también creo que no podemos este creer
en los sondeos de las encuestas en las
elecciones pasadas por ejemplo iba
ganando este hillary clinton en este
estado y gracias a los resultados de los
colegios electorales pues vimos que el
ganador terminó siendo trump
señor porras gracias por la información
y por estar aquí con nosotros en francés